[Musique]
et bon je ris verrier bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous c'est très
tard je n'ai national de général de
force ouvrière je vais y arriver
secrétaire général de force ouvrière on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes - une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenter ce
matin par patrice millions de naissances
bonjour assure patrice merci d'être là
on va bien sûr commencer par cette
allocution en d'emmanuel mâcon président
de la république qui a cité dimanche à
de nombreuses reprises les partenaires
sociaux est ce que vous vous dites ça y
est le tournant du quinquennat est enfin
là dans la relation entre emmanuel
macron il partenaires sociaux bien j'ai
effectivement entendu pas seulement
partenaires sociaux d'ailleurs moi je
dis plutôt les interlocuteurs sociaux
parce qu on est plutôt face à face que
partenaire la plupart du temps mais
ce que j'ai entendu aussi ses syndicats
à plusieurs reprises c'est rare dans la
parole du président la république et
négociation collective alors ses désirs
oui absolument jeu ça va plutôt dans le
bon sens maintenant ce que je constate
et ce qu'on avait souligné c'est que on
s'est souvenu de nous quand on s'est
aperçu qu'on avait peut-être un rôle
dans le contexte du confinement et de la
crise sanitaire notamment au regard des
contraintes qui sont soudainement venu
s'imposer dans le cadre de l'activité
économique et en particulier lorsqu'il a
fallu que un certain nombre
d'entreprises arrêtent leurs activités
parce qu'il fallait prioriser le
confinement heureusement que les
syndicats étaient là pour taper du poing
sur la table comme ça traînait un peu et
puis quand il a fallu surtout agir pour
que les équipements les organisations de
travail respecte les gestes barrière
dans les secteurs qu'ils ne pouvaient
pas s'arrêter là santé qui est mobilisée
aujourd'hui 1
et puis tous les salariés ce qu'on a
appelé la deuxième ligne moi j'aime pas
trop cela mais tous les salariés de la
chaîne d'approvisionnement qui ont
assuré la vie quotidienne des français
qui se sont mobilisés qui ne se sont pas
arrêtés jusqu'au caissière en passant
par les transporteurs les
manutentionnaires les agents les
salariés des services à domicile auprès
des personnes âgées des personnes
handicapées sans protection qui ne se
sont donc pas arrêté donc là
heureusement que les syndicats étaient
là et je peux vous dire que dans le
contexte du confinement j'entendais tout
à l'heure monsieur le président du sénat
monsieur larcher
je peux vous dire que les syndicats nous
n'avons pas arrêté on avait des journées
j'ai eu des journées remplies du matin
jusqu'au soir tard évidemment au
téléphone parce qu'on était beaucoup
questionné interpellé par nos délégués
nous syndicats qui eux mêmes étaient
interpellés par beaucoup de salariés qui
dans cette situation absolument
extraordinaire inédite s'interrogeait
avec beaucoup d'inquiétude bien sûr et
le cap fixé par le chef de l'état
écologie souveraineté solidarité est ce
que c'est le est ce que c'est les bonnes
orientations pour la france aujourd'hui
on a
beaucoup entendu de commentaires autour
de l'intervention du président de la
république sur le côté on a entendu à
nouveau des paroles mais concrètement
comment ça se traduit donc c'est
effectivement ce qui importe
aussi il faut la parole bien sûr mais il
faut que ça se traduise concrètement et
je le redis aujourd'hui par exemple il
ya eu des paroles sur les personnels du
secteur de la santé
et si aujourd'hui il ya des
mobilisations des manifestations c'est
parce que dans le contexte des
négociations qui se déroulent en ce
moment
eh bien on attend de voir comment
concrètement et évidemment ça va poser
un ajustement budget cela va se traduire
effectué justement vont parler de cette
journée de mobilisation puisque vous y
venez on reparlera après bien sûr du
discours d' emmanuel macron vous allez
participer voilà mobilisés avec mes
camarades de du secteur de la santé
la fédération des services vous serez
dans l'arrivée je serai dans la rue
devant ségur puisque c'est là que se
déroulent les négociations que le
ministre a appelé le ségur de la santé
vient certains certains soignants qui
demandent à leurs représentants de
quitter le ségur de la santé on a
entendu ça notamment la semaine dernière
vous caler votre position il faut y
participer à ce c'est dur ah ben je
vienne parler de négociation collective
partout force ouvrière fo
partout où on peut faire valoir et
défendre et faire progresser
l'intérêt des salariés on est là donc là
on est dans la négociation et on espère
bien se faire entendre
on verra ce qu en sera le résultat mais
pour le moment ce qu'on souhaite se
faire connaître ce que sont nos
revendications que ce soit sur les
aspects catégorielles de salaire de
rémunération de conditions de travail
mais aussi la façon de gérer l'hôpital
et la santé en général et revenir
réviser ces politiques qui étaient
essentiellement conduire sous l'angle de
l'économie budgétaire justement
aujourd'hui concrètement qu'est ce que
vous demandez au gouvernement sur ce
plan là alors il y a deux grands volets
il y à la revalorisation des métiers de
la santé
soignant et non soignant on ne distingue
pas à l'hôpital fonctionne par exemple
parce que il y a certes des médecins des
infirmiers des aides soignants mai
il ya des auxiliaires de services
hospitaliers des personnels techniques
de l'intendance et ces revalorisations à
quelle hauteur edouard philippe en
ouverture du ségur à parler de hausse
significatif pour vous cette ça doit
être quoi l'uci peut dire c'est que ce
que nos syndicats revendiquent c'est une
augmentation de l'ordre de 300 euros
pour l'ensemble des personnels mensuel
façon pourquoi parce que on sait qu'on
part et tout le monde en a entendu
parler à la situation des rémunérations
des personnels soignants et de la santé
en général
d'autres pays notamment dans l' ocde et
on sait qu'on a un retard de ce point de
vue donc il y à ce volet là et puis il
ya le volet des conditions de travail et
autour des conditions de travail les
conditions d'accueil des patients
donc la question des fermetures de lits
des restructurations de l' enveloppe
fermée ce qu'on appelle l'ondam
l'objectif national des dépenses
d'assurance maladie qui contraint les
établissements à gérer la rigueur en
réalité et c'est cela que nous voulons
voir réviser la présence de nicole notât
comme médiatrice est un plus dans ses
dents ce n'est guère de ségur de la
santé d'une manière générale ça n'est
pas la personne qui m'importe mais je
pense qu'il n'est jamais très heureux
[Musique]
allez sans doute elle fait de son mieux
j'imagine mais il n'est jamais très
heureux d'aller chercher un ou une
ancienne représentante syndicale pour
d'une certaine manière négociée en lieu
et place de l'interlocuteur employeurs
qui est l'état en l'occurrence avec les
syndicats quoi c'est pas cher des
tensions et des interrogations
et là il ya des tensions sur ce sujet je
ne sais pas encore une fois je ne sais
pas moi qui négocie c'est la fédération
fo du secteur de la santé par secteurs
leur volonté elle est aujourd'hui à un
moment donné de négocier directement
avec le ministère bien évidemment donc
sans passer par nicole notât
aujourd'hui c'est nicole notât qui est
chargé de recueillir et de mener des
discussions entre les différents
syndicats les différents acteurs et
demain une fois que
la synthèse aura été fait nous ce qui
nous importe c'est ce n'est pas nicole
notât qui représentera il faut ça c'est
clair
allez on va continuer à parler du
discours d' emmanuel macron vous nous
avez dit qu'il ya des mots qui vous ont
fait plaisir il ya une expression une
phrase qu'il a employée qui a été de
travailler il va falloir travailler et
produire davantage comment vous l'avez
entendu vous cette phrase travailler
davantage ben je l' ai déjà dit à
plusieurs reprises
c'est une parole ambigu parce que
c'était travailler et produire davantage
donc si il s'agit de faire en sorte que
en est une politique de relance de
l'activité économique de relocalisation
une politique de stratégie industrielle
qui fait qui fait qu' on recompte hier
une certaine souveraineté on a été tous
et toutes plus que étonné même si on
n'est pas surpris on le savait de
constater que nous n'étions pas
souverains en matière de médicaments de
matériel médical donc si il s'agit
effectivement d'aller dans ce sens et de
faire que on pourra créer de l'emploi et
faire que plus de salariés est un emploi
et un véritable emploi
ok si c'est nous dire que ceux qui ont
du boulot on va leur demander de se
retrousser les manches comme on
l'entendait pendant la période de
confinement aller au delà des 35 heures
au delà même des 48 heures c'est une des
ordonnances d'honteux j'aimerais
entendre aussi qu'elle est derrière nous
définitivement qu'on l'abandonnent
si c'est rogner sur les jours de congé
les jours de repos
ouvrir le dimanche plus que encore
aujourd'hui ça ça n'ira pas ça ne le
fera pas nous serons pas d'avoir refusé
sur les 35 heures pour contre productif
à tous points de vue
ce serait contre-productif parce qu'on a
besoin de faire en sorte que plus de
monde est un véritable emploi et
aujourd'hui on le sait on à un chiffre
des demandeurs d'emploi qui a explosé
notamment les contrats d'intérim non
renouvelé les contrats à durée
déterminée non renouvelés au moment du
confinement de celles et ceux là
n'attendent qu'une chose c'est d'avoir
un emploi un emploi pérenne alors bruno
le maire
tandis qu'à huit cent mille emplois qui
pourraient disparaître dans dans les
mois qui viennent est ce que ça vous
inquiète
est-ce que ça est ce que ça implique
dans les entreprises de passer des
accords de performance collective
est-ce que c'est l'option défendue par
geoffroy roux de bézieux avec des
accords de réduction du temps de travail
sur sur deux ans avec une prise en
charge par l'état qu'est ce que qu'est
ce que vous défendez vous de votre de
votre côté à il faut alors premièrement
oui nous sommes inquiets sur les
conséquences économiques du confinement
l'arrêt de l'économie pose beaucoup de
questions sur son redémarrage sa reprise
et dans un certain nombre de secteurs
il y a tout lieu de s'inquiéter de ce
que sera la reprise cela étant je pense
qu'il faut rompre avec ces discours qui
sont anxiogènes
il ne s'agit pas de nier la réalité et
la quiétude la certitude mais il faut un
discours dynamique engageant qui donne
confiance et de ce point de vue je moi
je ne suis pas économiste mais j'ai
toujours entendu que la confiance était
un des facteurs importants dans le
fonctionnement de l'économie et les
accords de performance collective la
petite musique qui consisterait à nous
dire dans ce contexte d'incertitudes de
difficultés il faut demander aux
salariés de faire un effort sur les
salaires sur le temps de travail les
congés etc
parce que l'économie va repartir plus
lentement
eh bien on aura créé un effet
contre-productif
d'une part ce serait injuste pour les
salariés concernés ne sont pas
responsables de cette situation
si on prend le secteur aérien ou le
secteur de l'aéronautique par exemple
c'était un secteur qui tirait l'économie
en matière d'innovation qui était très
favorable à la balance du commerce
extérieur de la france est tout à coup à
eux devraient se serrer la ceinture ce
serait injuste
d'une part et c'est vrai pour les autres
secteurs d'activité et ce serait
contre-productif parce que si vous ce
mail inquiétudes non seulement sur
l'emploi mais sur le salaire le pouvoir
d'achat et bien vous allez freiner la
consommation hors la france est un pays
pour lequel l'économie plus qu'ailleurs
plus qu'en allemagne tirée par la
demande intérieure la consommation
on s'inquiète beaucoup par exemple du
tourisme vous savez on va avoir du mal à
compenser
le déficit de visites de touristes
étrangers par du tourisme national
si en plus vous faites passer le message
aux français que ça va être plus dur sur
l'emploi est plus dure sur les salaires
mais sur ces efforts qui relance ses
efforts qui pourraient être demandés aux
salariés durant cette période l'état a
pris de nombreuses mesures pour sauver
l'emploi pour de mesures de chômage
partiel avec des milliards qui ont été
mis sur la table est ce qu'à un moment
c'est pas compréhensible de demander
aussi un effort aux salariés parce que
travailler 30 milliards tout de même le
coût du chômage partiel pris en charge
par l'état
oui mais vous savez si on ne fait pas de
l'activité partielle on indemnisera des
salariés qui seront au chômage tout
court
donc on n'aura pas gagné grand chose
sauf à moi les indemniser c'est toute la
difficulté qu'on a avec la réforme de
l'assurance chômage sur laquelle on est
en train de discuter donc sofia - les
années miser mais ça veut dire que on
rend plus difficile les fins de mois
pour ces salariés ont précarisent la
situation de ces salariés
et encore une fois c'est contre
productif sur le plan de la relance
économique
premièrement deuxièmement si
le la question de la relance
j'ai perdu j'ai fait d'excusés mais j'ai
perdu le fil de votre question le
chômage partiel mais on va on va venir
plus largement sur l'emploi puisque
emmanuel macron a dit que la bataille
pour l'emploi associer les partenaires
sociaux on sait qu'il ya des
négociations qui sont en cours en ce
moment même au ministère du travail on
en est ou de ces négociations
alors justement nous nous étions
demandeurs que on continue avec de
l'activité partielle parce que c'est ce
que je viens de vous dire si on ne prend
pas en charge la le soutien de l'emploi
dans les entreprises vous basculez
directement des salariés dans le chômage
et c'est beaucoup plus dur ensuite à la
fois on perd de la compétence on a plus
de mal à retrouver un emploi
tout le monde le sait et puis à des
secteurs dont on espère quand même qu'on
va réussir à les faire repartir et ce
qu'on attend avec aussi impatience c'est
qu'elle est ce qu'on nous dit être ou
devoir être le plan de relance dans
beaucoup de secteurs d'activité mais
juste sur ces négociations
est ce qu'il ya des choses qui bloque
les cadets point qui bloque quels sont
les points qui bloquent l'enjeu c'est
quel sera le niveau d'indemnisation des
salariés
c'était tout le risque est sale pointis
loi que la contrepartie soit de demander
aux salariés de se serrer la ceinture de
faire un effort sur les salaires et
encore une fois je viens de l'expliquer
mais ce serait absolument injuste et
contreproductif
est-ce que vous avez l'impression cette
fois d'être vraiment entendu parce que
votre homologue philippe martinez dit je
n'ai jamais autant parlé avec des
ministres que depuis le le début du
confinement et en même temps je crains
qu'il n'y ait pas de vraie négociation
est ce que vous avez l'impression
aujourd'hui que il ya un vrai dialogue
de vraies négociations avec le
gouvernement
alors question là c'est ce que je vous
disais au tout début on a on s'est
souvenu de nous quand on s'est aperçu
que
les syndicats jouent un rôle important à
tous les niveaux et y compris au niveau
national avec la ministre du travail le
premier ministre le président de la
république ça fait trois fois qu'on se
voit en deux mois ce qui est absolument
hors de l'ordinaire par rapport à ce
qu'on connaissait jusqu'à maintenant il
y a incontestablement un certain nombre
de sujets sur lesquels on a pu alerter
sur lesquels des réponses ont été
apportées
on a malheureusement fait le constat
qu'on a été à plusieurs reprises mis
devant le fait accompli
moi je me suis adressé directement au
premier ministre lui demandant de mettre
fin à cet état d'exception qu'est l'état
d'urgence sanitaire ça ne veut pas dire
que nous ne sommes pas soucieux de
l'urgence sanitaire mais que l'on mette
fin à ce qui est aujourd'hui la
possibilité pour le gouvernement de
gouverner par ordonnances par décret en
s'affranchissant y compris des
consultations obligatoire avec les
organisations syndicales notamment
or on a été confrontés à cela lorsque l'
ordonnance qui permettait et qui est en
vigueur jusqu'à la fin de l'année de
déroger aux 48 heures par exemple ce qui
est quand même assez extraordinaire les
48 heures sa date de 1919 de la première
convention internationale du travail
eh bien nous n'avons pas été consultés
notre avis ne nous a pas été demandé pas
plus que sur le raccourcissement des
délais de consultation par exemple des
conseils socio économiques dans les
entreprises ce qui était les comités
d'entreprise auparavant or nous avons
besoin de prendre le temps nécessaire
notamment aujourd'hui on a été confronté
à l'épisode de ryanair une des
difficultés c'est que l'entreprise
menaçait de supprimer des emplois si les
salariés qui sont les personnels
navigants commerciaux donc hôtesses et
stewards qui sont au smic dans cette
entreprise ne concédait pas de pouvoir
travailler mois avec un salaire réduit
de 20 % c'est-à-dire 20% en dessous du
smic
avec un temps de travail réduit
évidemment et bien ce que nous avions
demandé par exemple là c'est d'avoir une
réunion du csf immédiate avec une
expertise de la situation financière
économique de l'entreprise et ça ça vaut
dans tous les secteurs où on va être
confrontés à ses difficultés
donc là dessus
gouvernement à légiférer sans nous
demander notre avis c'est ça qui va
changer ça ça doit changer absolument
c'est pour ça que quand j'entends parler
de syndicats et de négociation
collective
je ne me fais pas non plus trop
d'illusions mais je préfère l'entendre
dans ce sens là que ne pas l'entendre du
tout voilà maintenant nous on va être
attentif et je redemande au gouvernement
formellement de mettre fin à l'état
d'exception qui lui permet de légiférer
par ordonnances et par décret en
s'affranchissant des consultations
obligatoires avec les syndicats allaient
un mot sur psa qui a créé la polémique
en envisageant de venir faire travailler
des salariés polonais dans une de ses
usines du nord le groupe est revenu sur
cette mesure en disant qu'il y aurait
des intérimaires moins de salariés
polonais ce que vous saluer ce recul je
pense je veux je voudrais pas entrer
dans un discours opposant les uns aux
autres les travailleurs qui viennent de
tel ou tel pays aux travailleurs
français c'est pas la logique par contre
il est effectivement pas compréhensible
qu'une entreprise qui par ailleurs
habituellement a recours à de l'intérim
ce qui est d'ailleurs aussi interrogatif
quand même là dans cette situation
présente alors qu'on sait que beaucoup
l'intérimaire attendre qu'une chose
c'est de retrouver un emploi à y
chercher des salariés ailleurs bon les
raisons
des salariés de son groupe voilà c'est
ça qu'ils ont groupés apparemment
c'était des raisons liées à une aptitude
professionnelle bon je connais pas
suffisamment le sujet dans le détail
maintenant ça soulève un problème qui a
été mis sur la table d'ailleurs
lorsqu'on a rencontré le président de la
république c'est les conditions du
travail détachées qui ne sont pas encore
complètement résolu loin s'en faut
on n'avait obtenu que à travail égal
salaire égal dans le pays d'accueil
le problème est que ce n'est pas encore
coût égal au sens où on y intègre les
cotisations enfin ce que représentent
les systèmes de protection sociale des
différents pays et là il ya un delta qui
fait du dumping social et ça c'est un
enjeu majeur quand on parle de
relocalisation de stratégie industrielle
il faut absolument que d'abord au niveau
européen qu'on arrive à harmoniser
justement les conditions sociales et ça
c'était le projet à l'origine de la
construction européenne mais qui est
toujours pas réalisé loin s'en faut et
sur lequel on a du mal à progresser
on a été confronté au contraire à des
dispositions de déréglementation et puis
ça pose le problème du respect des
normes internationales du travail qui
fait qu' on arrête de délocaliser des
emplois pour la seule et simple raison
qu'on va chercher du travail moins cher
ailleurs parce qu'on paye moins les
salariés parce que les conditions de
travail ne sont pas aussi respecter
qu'elles ne le sont dans notre pays mais
qu'il arsenic repasser petite chance
aussi que psa fasse venir des salariés
d'une usine de son groupe en pollen
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas normal enfin
encore une fois je n'oppose pas les
salariés jeu nous sommes
internationaliste nous sommes pour que
les travailleurs du monde entier soient
solidaires nous sommes partie prenante
de la confédération syndicale
internationale
par contre là où on a du chômage
on embauche avec jason veilleux qui
appelaient la solidarité européenne sur
ce sujet c'est la façon je voulais dire
geoffroy roux de bézieux ce que je dis
moi c'est qu'il faut embaucher tous ceux
qui sont aujourd'hui demandeurs d'emploi
dans notre pays à chaque fois qu'on le
peut d'abord un mot sur la réforme des
retraites pour finir le corps qui a
annoncé un chiffre assez vertigineux 30
milliards c'est le déficit du régime en
2020 due à la crise sanitaire est ce
qu'on peut se passer d'une réforme pour
ramener le régime à léquilibre encore
une fois si on rouvre ce dossier moi
j'avais prévenu avant que le président
de la république ne s'exprime dimanche
soir puisque on entendait revenir la
petite musique sur le fait que la
réforme des retaites finalement pourrait
revenir à l'agenda
j'avais prévenu en disant que ce serait
une grave erreur d'abord les raisons qui
faisait qu'on était opposé à ce projet
de système universel de retraite elles
sont toujours là elles n'ont pas changé
et je suis convaincu que nous avons
raison de ce point de vue on nous a dit
et ce déficit on le finance comment
alors le déficit il vient de quoi il
vient de l'arrêt de l'économie encore
une fois comme la dette qui s'est
amplifié avec le recours à l'activité
partielle en particulier si le déficit
on nous dit on va le financer en
reculant l'âge de départ à la retraite
bonjour pour les jeunes qui n'attendent
qu'une chose c'est de pouvoir rentrer
dans l'emploi nous nous avons une
proposition par exemple sur l'emploi des
jeunes
il y a de cela une vingtaine d'années on
avait mis en place qu'on avait appelé
l'arc une allocation retraite pour
l'emploi qui permettaient de compenser
un départ progressif à la retraite
appuyé par le système de retraite par
une embauche de jeunes mais alors du
coup est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
rouvrir ce débat on comprend pas bien
vous êtes contre la réforme des
retraites mais ça vous étiez content
mais ce que vous êtes prêt à rouvrir le
débat et à discuter d'une nouvelle
réforme peut-être d'une autre réforme à
mai depuis le début nous nous avions dit
que nous demandions qu'une chose c'est
qu'on revienne au point de départ donc
là de la comptable actuelle vous êtes
prêt à rouvrir des négociations à
nourrir des dispenses palpable contexte
se prête à ouvrir un grand débat sur le
dossier des retraites je le redis nous
avons un système de retraites dans notre
pays qui remplit son office qui garantit
un droit à la retraite à tout un chacun
dont on nous a reproché d'ailleurs qu'il
était plutôt favorable par rapport à ce
qui se passe ailleurs dans d'autres pays
nous n'allons pas à en rougir
l'urgence n'est pas à remettre sur la
table une réforme d'ampleur des
retraite merci beaucoup merci verrier
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin merci
patrice demain vos classes ce sera sa
liste guérini le délégué général de la
république en marche